hey guys it's Anne welcome to the
channel if you're new here this is a
indoor worm farming Channel and this is
my experimental bin that I am trying to
see how many inputs it takes to get to
my final batch of castings so right now
what we're looking at is
21.3 pounds and I'll put kilograms down
there below so we're going to jump right
in and I'll put below what the weight
was when we left last time in general
we've been losing about a pound and a
half of water probably I mean there
could be carbon dioxide losses
Etc
so yeah there could be carbon dioxide
losses ammonia losses whatever
um but for the most part we have noticed
that it has been moisture related at
this moment everything looks very very
wet I think the bubble wrap has been
doing more than its job to keep this
nice and moist for the worms so they can
reproduce and eat properly
so let me kind of dig in here I am
seeing cocoons in here so they are
reproducing
and the worms are looking nice and
Wiggly
this is a mix of my red wiggler and
European Nightcrawler and Blue Worms
that is in blue and nowhere else except
for this one right now last time we came
in we actually fed a liter of pumpkin on
each side now I'm not saying anything
over here maybe a few little orange
flecks
uh but now we're gonna go over to this
side where we fed all of the new leaves
to give them some bedding
now put in the comments below what do
you think it's going to take in the
amount of
inputs over the course of the next
I don't know it's it's been a couple of
months since we started this
I'm probably going to go all the way to
Spring
and uh we'll see you know the weight of
the castings at a particular moisture
and I'll check to see what percentage of
moisture it is
and then we'll see what we get in the
way of
castings
so I have been measuring everything
separately so I've been measuring the
volume of the food as well as the mass
of the food
and the water and the bedding so
everything should be accounted for and
then when we come in week over week
actually month over month at this point
and looking in on the worms what we're
doing is seeing what did we lose
as far as weight goes over the course of
that time and it's been nearly a month
since we checked in on this bin so I'll
put all the numbers below but they did
eat almost all their food they've got
quite a bit in the way of
shredded coconut choir and leaves in
here and I do still see a little bit of
potato
but it looks like other than that the
moisture is doing really well which uh
I'm going to have to drain off some of
the moisture on the food that I brought
down for them because I don't really
think it needs it it's quite wet
okay so this is what they're getting and
this should total about one gallon of
food or about four liters
and this is going to be a combination of
avocado and tomato
and we'll put that on this side now
they're actually getting the whole
avocado I had purchased some that never
did ripen after about a month so it they
might have been picked a little bit too
early or something so we're going to put
that over on that side
and then the rest of the gallon of food
will put back over on this side and then
we will weigh what everything is next
yes I did forget to weigh this
separately but with a little bit of worm
math I can
figure out what I've put in here so this
is bananas and bread and more avocados
no water additions this time so let's
see what the weight is up to now
26.5 pounds so we've added about five
pounds of food in one gallon
and I'll put the metric conversions in
there I'm going to add a little bit of
grit because I don't think that avocado
is going to be easy to eat
I do tend to forget
to do things like this for some reason
but I am going heavy especially on
something that's going to be as hard to
digest as the avocado flesh
so hopefully that will be enough food to
get them going for the next three weeks
or so until I can get back in here again
here we are the final weight of
27.1 pounds
so if you're thinking this is a very
cool experiment I have a whole playlist
just for this experiment which I will
link over there and if you've already
seen that YouTube thinks you're gonna
like that video right over there alright
guys thanks for hanging out with me and
my worms and everybody have a good day